ينضم إلي الآن الدكتور عمر عبد المنان
وهو طبيب أعصاب أطفال أه
يعمل بشكل مكثف في غزة منذ عام 2011
وأسس أصوات غزة الطبية شكرا
جزيلا لانضمامك إلينا لا أعرف أه
إذا حاولت الحصول على
اتصالاتك في غزة  أردت فقط
التعرف على الاتصالات لأننا
نفهم أنهم جميعًا
معطلون، نعم تمامًا ماكس، لذلك فقط
لإطلاعك على آخر المستجدات، نحن فريق من الأطباء
الذين كانوا على اتصال مباشر
مع الأطباء والجراحين
على  الأرض في غزة منذ أه اليوم الأول
من هذا والذي ربما يكون قبل 18 يومًا
الآن في آخر أه ما يقرب من 24 ساعة
الآن أه منذ الساعة 6 بتوقيت المملكة المتحدة أمس
والذي أعتقد أنه كان حوالي الساعة 1:00
بالتوقيت الشرقي، لم يكن لدينا صفر  صفر رسائل،
صفر القدرة على إجراء مكالمات هاتفية وانعدام
التواصل على الإطلاق مع أكثر من
300 شخص حاولنا الاتصال بهم،
أطباء تأشيرة، جراحون،
مسعفون، أه إخوة، أخوات، آباء،
أمهات، أصدقاء زملائنا، ولا
نحصل على أي
اتصال مباشر على الإطلاق، لذلك
لم يكن هناك أي اتصال مباشر  صوت روح بشرية واحدة
سُمع من غزة منذ
مساء أمس، وهذا وضع غير مسبوق
إلى حد كبير، وهذا مقلق للغاية بسبب
انعدام الاتصالات،
أصدر الحاضر الفلسطيني الأحمر
بيانًا بالأمس يقول فيه إن
حقيقة عدم وجود اتصالات
صادرة من غزة تضعك في موقف صعب.  المرضى
والأطباء وأه السكان المعرضون لخطر
الإصابات الجماعية، فهم غير قادرين على
الاتصال بسيارات الإسعاف على الرقم 101 وهو
خط المساعدة للطوارئ، ولا يمكنهم
التحقق من أفراد أسرهم إذا كانوا
على قيد الحياة أم لا، ونحن
منزعجون حقًا من ذلك  الآثار المترتبة على هذا
التعتيم بصراحة أم هذا أه
مستوى جديد من الأراضي الجديدة التي لم
ندخلها أبدًا قبل أن تقضي الأمم المتحدة أمس
كل شيء بعد كل المساء بينما كان هذا
يحدث في مناقشة ما إذا كان بإمكانهم التوصل إلى
وقف لإطلاق النار وقد رددوا
ذلك منذ أكثر من أسبوع وحذروا  من المخاطر
التي تم نقلها مباشرة من الأمم المتحدة،
خطر حدوث إبادة جماعية في غزة في الوقت
الحالي، هناك آلاف
الوفيات بين المدنيين، يموت طفلان
كل 15 دقيقة في غزة، وأنا
متأكد تمامًا من أن هذا المعدل قد ارتفع في
الآونة الأخيرة  12 ساعة أغلبية الوفيات
من النساء والأطفال بكميات غير متناسبة وهذا
الحرمان المستمر للمدنيين من الأشياء التي
لا غنى عنها لبقائهم على قيد الحياة، الغذاء،
الماء، الإنترنت
للاتصال بخطوط الهاتف للتواصل هو خنقهم
يخنقهم حرفيا